Donald Trump has been ramping up his
attacks on the Clinton Foundation he's
actually referred to it as a criminal
enterprise and there's now a sort of new
wrinkle to this story which is that the
Trump foundation happens to be a top
donor to that Clinton Foundation which
Trump has criticized as a criminal
enterprise a Barack Obama's former
campaign manager David pluff noted that
the Clinton Foundation has worked on
hiv/aids work on malaria and also noted
over the weekend in an interview that
Donald Trump has his fair share of ties
to the Clinton Foundation PolitiFact
decided to look into this and it turns
out that indeed it is true at minimum
the Trump foundation has donated 100
thousand dollars to the Clinton
Foundation and possibly quite a bit more
the cumulative lifetime donation which
is how these donations are sort of
categorized by donation data indicate
that Trump is a contributor to the
degree of somewhere between 100,000 and
one dollars to 250 thousand dollars now
it's not completely clear whether Trump
himself made a personal contribution or
whether it was through the Donald J
Trump foundation which of course is
controlled by Donald Trump which donated
over one hundred thousand dollars in
2009 reserved a table at the Clinton
Foundation Gala in twenty ten for ten
thousand dollars donald trump's daughter
Ivanka is also listed as a donor to the
Clinton Foundation 5,000 up one to ten
thousand dollars and her father-in-law
Charles Kushner gave somewhere between
250 thousand and five hundred thousand
dollars and you might hear that amount
and say okay Clinton Foundation they
have tons and tons of donors where does
this level of donation put Trump in his
foundation Trump's gift to the Clinton
Foundation places him in the top 0.2
percent of the Foundation's donors most
of the
three hundred thousand donors gave under
two hundred and fifty dollars this is
fascinating to me for a couple of
reasons on the one hand we know because
of a Washington Post investigation that
Donald Trump has actually not given that
much of his own money to his own
foundation so he likes to tout his
amazing charitable donations when
actually he hasn't even funded his own
foundation for a very very long time if
you are going to say that you are in
charge of that foundation though in
spite of the fact that you haven't
actually contributed that much of your
own money you can't say when it is
revealed that you've donated over a
hundred thousand dollars through that
foundation that hey that's my foundation
that doesn't have anything to do with me
this is a real problem for Trump Jason
in that this is a a a criminal
enterprise as he has described it and he
has participated in building up the
supposed criminality I think we're just
getting ready for the ultimate flip-flop
here Trump in his own heart is actually
Hillary supporter and at the end of the
day he's gonna have to admit this this
is what many people are emailing me
about and saying David are you now ready
to say that this entire Trump thing is
clearly just to help Hillary Clinton we
have the pictures of the Clintons and
the Trump together we know about the
wedding attendance of of uh Hillary
Clinton to Trump's wedding these are
friends none of the critiques that
Donald Trump has seemed to really carry
much credibility or weight and that this
is not a bid to his credit and this is
crazy that this is the silver lining
Donald Trump has not denied donating to
the Clinton Foundation Trump uh has has
sort of deliberately but couched it as I
know how to play the game and this sort
of gets us to that question that many
people are emailing me about fine Trump
played the game and used his money too I
guess by influence um we don't know
exactly how he did that what's worse the
fact that Hillary Clinton is the one
using the Clinton Foundation allegedly
to broker influencer that Trump took
advantage of the system that's in place
that's a a perfectly legitimate and in
interesting question but how on earth
will the Trump supporters say well we
don't care about the fact that Trump
participated in the donations to what he
called the criminal enterprise the
problem is only the supposed criminal
enterprise but then I remember Jason his
supporters probably won't care at all
about this yeah I mean they're just
waiting to see all these economic tax
document status you know show show all
here is ensures cars at some point yeah
it might just be after he loses the
November election or wins depending on
how it goes I don't expect to see those
tax records anytime soon